good morning millennials welcome back to
the toast happy
Friday
gotta get down I'm red
Friday we did it Friday night I gotta
get down on Friday everybody's looking
forward to the weekend weekend hey Jax
howdy girl it's Friday
yes yes it is I thought you were gonna
ask me about me so I was just like
waiting for the Hat the hyd but it never
came but I'm doing okay you know
something that happens when we do this
show is that I have to pick the stories
like so I spend 30 minutes before the
show picking the stories that go all
over the Internet and the news is so
awful I know that it's so hard to then
just like find like five fun stories to
talk about and then like not just think
about all of the Terrible Things I just
saw I know that's true I actually never
thought about that part of the job
because you picked the stories I'm sorry
that you get to go through that some
days are worse than others like today
was particularly harrowing especially
when I get on The Daily Mail like but
actually it's not even just Daily Mail
like People magazine you think it would
be like fun fluff yeah the True Crime
section you know it's hard for real life
they have a section that's true crime
they have a section that's real life and
it's real life is always [__]
horrible I'm so sorry
um
but that's kind of like the miracle of
the toast that's why we do what we do to
like filter through those horrible
things and just give you the positivity
but it's hard to bounce back sometimes
after I've seen what I've seen you're
literally like the Joker like you make
everyone laugh but on the inside you're
deeply unwell
there's like where's the piece for me
you know you're jacking Phoenix
I'm Jackie O Phoenix and so yeah that's
just like it's so I usually forget by
the time you start recording but like
today I haven't forgotten there are a
number of stories that were just
upsetting upsetting oh my god well I'm
gonna make you laugh today hey Jax how
you doing oh thanks mclared I'm doing
well also because it is Friday which is
magnificent news for everyone
um especially you and I because we do
love the day of the fry we do love the
day of the fry um Overjoyed you know a
Friday isn't any less special when you
have the Monday off you know
yeah agreed we it's Friday no matter how
you slice it because there are some
weeks where it's so long and it's like
it's just Friday so take the wins where
you could get them I hope everyone has
really exciting weekend plans do you
have I know you're hanging out with
Shannon yeah I'm seeing Shannon tonight
for dinner which I'm so excited about I
have like so much I feel like she's such
good gossip I like need to sit her down
and just study her
um and I also just haven't seen her in
like literally months because she's
always gallivanting around the globe so
yeah we're on a fabulous restaurant
we're gonna look fabulous I'm finally
like really making some headways Headway
Headway with my Dyson air app I did
purchase it almost maybe two maybe three
years ago
um I gave it a shot when I got it and I
got so frustrated and I don't know what
compelled me to just like try it again
Shannon helped me she has a tutorial she
does um
she's like a subscription on her
Instagram which a lot of people are
doing now I think it's really
interesting and I feel like Shannon's
the perfect person to do it because
she's like So Glamorous like I can't get
enough and I watched her tutorial and
like literally the hair would not wrap
around the barrel for me it was like so
annoying and I thought it was because
you know my hair is too long and thick I
have to get the bigger Barrel oh no it's
so long and thick how hard for you I
know
but it turns out that the air app has a
filter and I didn't know that I need to
clean it or else like it won't suction
like the bottom thing comes off there
was so much dust oh my God it was
disgusting and the second I figured that
out it started wrapping
huh and now I remember that's good for
me to know as someone who uses the air
app every week oh okay and so when the
air wrap when it came to my house it
came with all the you know accoutrements
I put them all in the box and there was
this little like circular brush thing
and I'm like what the [__] is this and I
threw it out it's the brush for the
filter to get all the dust out and now I
had to use I had to throw away my
toothbrush and use my toothbrush to get
it was like so annoying
oh my god wow okay I'm gonna try that
too I use my Dyson air up a little
differently than you use your ears and I
like the way I use mine except when my
hair when I don't have a fresh haircut
like it really won't hold yeah so I've
kind of just given up right now uh I'm
gonna get better I'm gonna give it a new
life I'm getting a haircut on Monday in
addition to this being the year of yes
it's also the year I like start
um like proactively doing things so I'm
getting a haircut I actually have a
physical I have not had a physical
um in 200 years yes and I feel like now
that I'm not um like now that I've lost
weight like I feel like every time I
went to the doctor it's like well you
could lose weight I'm like no I know I'm
not dumb like I know I'm extremely
unhealthy like you think if I like
wanted to be this way and I would it's
not a choice [__]
um and now that I've lost some weight I
feel like I'm sure she'll still tell me
I'm still like medically obese but I'm
sure she'll tell me but I'm on my way
you know
yeah no we looked at the BMI you're not
medically obese no I am
were you yeah no it goes like I thought
that was not the conclusion that we came
to no it was it goes like you're and by
the way BMI is so like toxic and
unrealistic like I feel like BMI is not
accurate but technically no but okay BMI
like when you go by they say I should be
like 103 pounds it's literally saying I
might even in 2019 like not even close
and I'm saying higher Flames but they
give you a window and like the top of my
normal window normal according to BMI
like I think it's pretty generous I
don't think BMI is like that crazy
because yes the low number is pretty low
but like there's a a big green window
that they give you I don't and then they
give you a yellow window I personally
like I don't [__] with the BMI but it is
a frame of reference that people often
use so I'm just using it here and the
IBM I would consider me obese and then
under obese is overweight and that's
kind of like goals
um I'm not there yet
okay but we were looking at it and like
you weren't you weren't far off yeah but
I wasn't I wasn't super close I feel
like you were saying I'm not I'm not
letting the BMI dictate my life like BMI
is toxic you're doing this for you but
like now that you're having these gains
like it's cool to see where you like
stack up to this thing that like has
always been the evaded you yeah but so
all set to say is I'm taking care of me
this year I'm going to the doctor for a
physical I am going to the dentist I
haven't made that appointment yet
because honestly that's worse than the
physical I absolutely hate the dentist
and the last time I went probably maybe
over a year ago uh she said I had a
cavity and I should come back and I
didn't I just like hoped I would brush
the cavity away
not how cavities work but if it's not
bothering you it must not be that bad no
it's not bothering me but I do feel like
I could get a cleaning like I'm just
it's the beginning of the year I just
got a cleaning I feel like the beginning
of the year is a good time to make all
your appointments haircut doctor dentist
anything else you know full body skin
check oh I got to do that I just did
that I want to get a haircut I got it I
think I'm gonna get my hair cut down
here because I don't even ask for like
anything crazy it's not like I'm going
for a new look just to trim
maybe I'll do that with my new vehicle
while I still have it I only have a few
more days left on my loner car from our
friends at GM I didn't talk about on the
toast yesterday but GM sent me a car
they sent me like this cute gorgeous
Cadillac and I didn't drive yesterday
which feels like a waste but I needed a
day off like driving is a lot for me it
requires so much mental it like I get so
much adrenaline from the whole thing
that like
it's not a casual experience but today
I'll be back in my car because I only
have a few days left with it you should
drive to get bangs
you should get bangs you know what
like no but I actually think you might
look good with bangs I don't think you
don't think
no I don't think so I have a very round
face I think that bangs benefit round
faces no no then you're just like a
middle curtainy bowling ball well if you
get bad bangs then there's nothing to be
done no no even good like there's no
need for me to get things but I think
you should get banged I've like always
secretly wanted them I had side bangs in
the seventh grade actually at my bum
it's I had side bangs and they were they
were my pride and joy like I I couldn't
believe I was allowed to get them and
when I got them I was obsessed because I
was very much like the emo time you know
Secondhand Serenade Fall Out Boy for me
like I've got I've gotten to live my
bangs fantasy and it was just that it
was fantastic it was amazing Parisian
bangs are like when they're all over
your forehead and then they're in the
middle like they're yeah that like
cropped bang look is never gonna work
for me not the bang
not that one no but
some people do it yeah yeah it's not for
me
um so I don't know maybe this is a sign
if you've been thinking about getting
bangs that you should not you Jackie are
listeners that you should do it
yeah Claudia wants to see yeah I like I
love the bangs Journey for people I know
it's like such a hassle to grow them out
and it's fun at first and then it's not
because you can't style them I know but
I don't know you should do it
yeah that's not like you always are
itching to get bangs when you sit down
for a haircut like I'm always itching
for like a bob that's what I would
advocate for like I think anybody who's
considering just going short should
totally do it it was one of the better
things I've ever done I am so here for
Bobby O making a return Theo's crying I
was like he wants jackets oh my God
Claudia I literally didn't know Tia was
in there and I was like what is going on
at Cody's does she have a baby in the
studio yeah
Castillo's so excited he said Auntie is
getting her Bob again no no I will but
not for a few years
it was such a great time when you had a
bob it was a great time and I feel like
when it comes back it's going to even be
even better because like I'm even better
at my hair now I'm better at my makeup
and I was so against it when you got it
I'm like you're crazy you're crazy
but now you're the one who's always
asking for me to get it back but no I
work too hard to grow my hair this long
I think it like suits me you work too
hard for this ZIP code to go home now
ain't that the truth ain't that the
truth
um we got an amazing show it's Friday
Theo's here Jax is here what else
genuinely this is a genuine question
what else could you ask for maybe a
little honestly Bryce oh right
that would be the only other thing um
but he's doing Bryce things this morning
unfortunately
and we miss him
God Rest his soul so it's not a full
stride day but it's a thriving so good
so good still good especially because we
haven't seen Theo in the studio in a
while to what do we owe this pleasure
you know it's Friday uh his uh walk
ended early you know like the timing the
stars were aligned
we love that for him hi my angel man you
want to say hi to everyone oh I love you
so much
oh I [__] look at this guy you know
those Bryce and Strikes they hate these
chairs because there's no room space for
them no and now I do remember why I
stopped bringing Theo to the show like
I'm so distracted like the way you can't
text and drive you can't pod and Thrice
I know unless we're together and the
boys are together and then it's just
like a feast for the sentences but he's
just wandering around the studio like
sniffing around and like I'm obsessed
he's so cute I miss that boy he's such
an angel crunchy Angel man crunchy Angel
man
speaking of musical wait wait I finished
the sound of music last night oh how was
it amazing it was so good mclared you
should really watch it it was so premium
they really don't make them like that
anymore they don't every the songs were
so good and then like the score was
amazing and the scenery and the story it
was just garages and I'm so glad that
we've had this Renaissance right Sound
of Music and I have to owe it to that
weird-ass story I picked the other day
yeah about the baroness and now that I
watch The Sound of Music I know who the
baroness character is she was like meant
to be like evil stepmother except she
wasn't evil like gay org I don't know
why they can't call him George Georg the
father oh my God he brings Hood Gaylord
this he brings home this wench from
Vienna she's a widow and she wants to
marry him because he's wealthy but I
think they also like get along and they
have a good time
um but then he falls in love with the
governess and so he sends her on her way
and even though the baroness did try and
get rid of Julie Andrews and like she
was a little nefarious like of course
she's stepping in on her man of course
she's literally textbook like you know
protect your opinions
like no like the nanny who's like making
eyes totally the dad so she had to go
100. she had to go so
um and then when Georg does break up
with the baroness you think she's gonna
be like spiteful and say something nasty
but instead she cuts him off and like
she breaks up with him to like he's like
she's really cute anyways I guess it's
gonna be a baroness origin story oh
that's cool I think
will be nice because she wasn't such an
evil character by the way speaking of
The Sound of Music Jackie and I were
shocked and
taken aback that The Sound of Music
official Instagram accounts this is
craziest thing the standard music
official Instagram account followed us
commented on one of our clips from uh on
reels where we were talking about the
sound of music and they left a comment
and it said this synopsis left no crumbs
like obviously it's a gen Zer on that
account and she's doing a very good job
but I wasn't expecting Julie Andrews to
use like some Modern Tick-Tock phrase
no no I was really shocked by that
response and in a good way I was shocked
but I was I was really shocked but they
have a really pop in Social presence
they celebrate all the cast members
birthdays they post fans are cute you
know so it's it's nice to see and I know
it's only January but if we're gonna
start like a list for 2023 of films that
are good when spending holiday time with
your family I think the sound of music
is the first on our list
yes it is already on my list I put it
there last night and last night I was
doing some more research about like the
Trap family like now they go by the
traps they drop the Vaughn when they
came over I think that's the best
yeah but they're so iconic as the Von
trap Family Singers
uh what did I learn about them oh that
the movie like when during the Cold War
when there was like threat of nuclear
war like I guess the government put
together a list of movies they were
gonna play for people to watch while
nuclear war played out and sounded music
was one of them see it's a Timeless film
we need to get a hold of that list yes
add it to our holiday list
exactly
um so like I said gorgeous show gorgeous
girls gorgeous day of the week
yes and I think without further adieu we
should get on with it I'll show you into
the weekend with the fast five stories
that you yes you I know you think no I
know I I I'm on Tick Tock I know you
don't you you don't know these ones that
you need to know
today's episode is brought to you by
Spritz Society a gorgeous sparkling
cocktail in a can a company founded by
Yours Truly Jackie O It's a real Family
Affair here and you know it's January
what 16th we've all given up on July
January especially the team at Spritz
Society we've already given up Spritz
Society sparkling cocktails are better
tasting and better for you they're made
with real wine they are low sugar but
they still have that six percent ABV
they take all natural recognizable
ingredients and they pack them into
convenient sparkling canned cocktails
that you can take anywhere oh for our
gluten-free girlies Gwyneth Paltrow yeah
that's right we're gluten free
if you haven't already heard we were
also named the best canned cocktail by
USA Today if there isn't a reason to
choose these sparkling cocktails then we
don't know what is we've got five
flavors y'all and we've got a new one
coming out I think in like a few months
it's a collab with one of your favorite
influencers it's not me and Jackie that
was misleading
um but currently we got Peach which is
really turning into a fan favorite
grapefruit my favorite blood orange more
bitter more traditional Spritz Vibes
pineapple and which one did I not say
snitch's favorite lemon a refreshing
Brian Kelly's favorite there's really
something forever and there isn't one
that Reigns Supreme like everyone has
their own Vibe mcclurdio material Spritz
Society is more personal than comedy
more personal than food more personal
than poetry
so we have a special code for the
toaster is if you use code dry January
you will get 20 off the site for the
next 24 hours it is a big code we
usually don't do 20 so that's 20 off all
products and subscriptions at
spritzociety.com so we also offer
monthly subscription so if you drink
wine a lot and you want to make sure you
never run out you can get on the Spritz
subscription model and if you use the
code dry January you'll get 20 off your
first month okay so that's
s-p-r-i-t-z society.com code
dry January that was stunning today's
episode is also sponsored by betterhelp
when you're at your best you can do
great things but sometimes life gets you
bogged down and you may feel overwhelmed
or like you're not showing up in the way
that you want to working with a
therapist can help you get closer to the
version of you because when you feel
empowered you're more prepared to take
on everything life throws at you therapy
is such a fabulous tool to help you work
through things in life life is never
easy it has Peaks and valleys it's like
a roller coaster and having something
really stable someone really stable to
talk to like better help is so helpful
what's great about better help is that
it's all done online So Gone are the
days of waiting in Waiting rooms you
know awkward social interactions you can
chat you can video you can call with
your therapist if you don't you know
Vibe with your therapist which is really
natural they make it really easy to
switch it up until you find someone that
fits so if you're thinking of giving
therapy a try better help is a great
option it is convenient it is flexible
it is Affordable and again it's done
entirely online just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and you can switch
therapists at any time and there's no
additional charge which is really nice
so if you want to live a more empowered
life therapy can get you there visit
betterhelp.com toast today to get 10 off
your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash toast betterhelp.com
t-o-a-s-t it is never too late to start
working on the most important person in
your life that's you
get the tools to get through things that
are difficult because life is not going
to get easier but you can you can get
easier with better help
thank you mcclurgia letterio for sure
deal you're welcome
our first story I'm glad to put a pin in
this conversation yes from the entire
week that Selena Gomez has clarified her
relationship status amid the dating
rumors that she is with Drew Taggart
from The Chainsmokers Selena Gomez
clarified she is single and has since
deleted Instagram story post on Thursday
amid rumors she is dating The
Chainsmokers member Drew Taggart she
said quote I like being alone too much
against a photo a black and white photo
of the sky behind a mountain range and
she added the hashtag hashtag I am
single and then she deleted it a few
minutes later but of course
she posted it okay first of all I'm
shocked that like for once your denial
actually came true like I feel like you
were in denial about Kim and Kanye
you're like constantly in denial about
things and you had you had actually good
proof and really good reasoning to the
point where you actually convinced me
that these two were not dating like
you're right they got pictures of them
in a bowling alley where they're
apparently making out but nobody took a
picture of them making out sure no you
were 100 right I'm shocked that you're
like vehement denial actually turned out
to be true
yes and this is a situation where you
have to trust your gut like the other
situations when like Kim and Kanye were
getting divorced like I was in denial
because I was just processing my grief
of course like I didn't have reasons I
wasn't like no for this this and this
they will be together like I think
everybody couldn't tell that I was just
processed yeah yeah yeah but you're this
I trusted my intuition and I said that
the truth booth said they are not a
match but what's so weird is that she
posted this photo
um which was very clear but there
actually was a man in the bottom right
corner and there was a head of a man I
thought when I first saw before I read
the text I'm like
oh her and Drew like relationship
confirmation so to say you're single but
then to accidentally have your friends
like who's a man's head like in the
bottom of the frame is just misleading
oh for sure
um the whole thing is like kind of an
interesting response like considering
Slinger doesn't need to respond like
you're single and she doesn't she
doesn't really ever respond I have
another theory now that just came to me
it's I I think it's like a cons like a
bit of a conspiracy theory but I'm just
gonna keep reading into everything okay
so she hashtagged I am single the name I
feel like
she has a single coming out called I am
or it's called I am single or it's
called I like being alone too much or
that's like the no that's like the first
lyric I like being alone too much to
dance with your heart that was good oh
man not me like making up like a Madonna
song I was about to ask you if that's a
real song no oh my God that's so nice
I'm quaking it's the first sign of I am
wait what did I say I like being alone
too much to dance with you dance with
your heart who literally who am I
I've never said that phrase in my entire
life sometimes like my artistic side
just takes over
keep going this might be better than I
drink wine okay
I like being alone too much to dance
with your heart but when I'm alone I get
lonely in the dark
should I write this on
keep going I don't want to push my luck
honestly okay but you could skip to the
chorus of I am single how would that go
and would you is it I am the single or I
am
okay and it'd be like I don't know I
forgot the melody already I'm nervous
there's too much pressure no no but the
chorus is different than the bridges so
you could start fresh
I need a minute I am
I am and it would need to be like
different phrases like I am great not
great but like Rave I am free I am me
and that's how I would end like I am me
and then I am single yeah no single
doesn't work but that opening line I
like being alone too much to dance with
you what did I say after that sometimes
yeah that's also how songwriters
we're all up in my hair
sometimes I can remember if you were
even there something like that something
like that but sometimes when songwriters
write they do a little bit of like
somebody else
is this already a song or am I making up
like the most sickening Melody it's not
a song this is not a song
so good
I'm obsessed
Claudia you need to get into the studio
yeah inspiration has struck no and like
it's important to know I have two songs
out they're amazing I had nothing to
really to do with the writing of any
except for like a few notes you know
like I'm not I didn't do the Melody I
had like people do that for me so this
is the first time I'm like kind of like
finding my artistic side like I'm up you
know what I just need to really I mean
never mind I was like oh that was so
dumb oh my God I was like you're gonna
voice you know before voice note I'm
like this is literally being recorded
literally I like being alone
obsessed oh my God I hope that this is
the case for Selena but and even if it
is like you could still write your song
because now we'll have two songs called
I am no what if like Selena hears this
and then like changes her song and like
steals my idea
oh but she hasn't contacted you she
would never she loves me and also like
enough people listen to this podcast for
us to really get some momentum yeah like
we'd have the people on our side yeah
cool
cool well I hope that I'm right about
this being like phase one of a single
announcement the launch
yeah that would just make this whole
soccer really exciting can I tell you
how when you used to live here and we're
you know my friend and my sister
um you bought a box of tissues for the
studio and you were like I don't know
like I feel like we need tissues we have
paper towels we've never had a box of
tissues I'm just now finishing them it
is the greatest gift you ever gave me
no I just ordered more on Amazon tissues
are so underrated like I know I have a
box here too and I actually just used
one this morning I had a sniffer I'm
always wiping my nose with toilet paper
or paper towel or like honestly my
sleeve
but tissues I feel like I only get
tissues if I'm like really sick and it's
like why
yeah why I have tissues all over my
house that's a Zack thing but it's
really nice it's gorgeous yeah
just wanted to shout out to tissues
these are Puffs these code toast and I'm
kidding puffs.com code toast gets you no
discount and probably is a link that
doesn't work and probably like puts you
on some list you know
um wait what was I gonna say you know
what's such good marketing is like I
cannot say Puffs without Puffs Plus
indeed yeah
yes I do
it's so sweet I like that commercial
I'm glad
you come back to next story if you want
to
okay our next story is a little shady
news because Vanessa Hudgens reacted to
her ex Austin Butler's viral Elvis
accent so Vanessa has stayed mom as
Austin has ascended to previously
unimagined greatness greatness but she
she's now just by saying one word so
Paige just posted an article saying
Austin Butler's Elvis accent is genuine
and might remain forever said a voice
coach then an Instagram user commented
saying he went to the Lady Gaga School
of Oscar campaigning then the Nessa
commented crying like she responded to
that guy's comment not she a lot of
people thought you were crying to the
post of page six which was the article
no she was responding to someone's funny
comment yeah that he went to the Lady
Gaga School of Oscar campaign acting
yeah
um did Lady Gaga like have her accent
it wasn't an accent but she became Ali
like she was there was no it was
indistinguishable who was who oh I was
thinking House of Gucci sorry oh no she
went hard for Star is Born that's what I
think about when I think about Oscar
campaign yeah yeah but I was thinking
about accent or or is this guy saying I
don't really get his joke like I don't
think it's that funny that like Vanessa
needed to comment like sometimes people
yeah sometimes people I guess hysterical
comments like I guess I just pretended
to understand to be a part of something
yeah or or is he saying you remember how
Lady Gaga said like a million times
there could be a hundred people like
that's what I think of when I think of
Lady Gaga Oscar campaigning there could
be a hundred people in a room she said
that in every interview and maybe like
his thing is like he's gonna say that a
thousand times like this is his voice I
don't know oh that's not what I got I
got really like you forget now but like
when it was her turn with Star is Born
like her and Bradley were they dating
were they not dating like she was just
like
at all times being her character from
the movie and that's what Austin is
doing at all times being Elvis right
like they had those Billboards all
throughout la like of Lady Gaga as Ali
the pop star and like being like Ally
the pop star new music
and if you need reminding like remember
Nina dobrev's yeah Halloween costume the
dumbest thing anyone's ever done okay
but but it's helpful in this situation
because she dressed as a baby no a star
a star baby being born no she was
dressed as a baby wearing a star because
it was she was just born a star is born
okay and then she had like a sign that
said like campaigning for an Oscar
I sneezed on it it's true bless you
um yeah I just honestly the comment
isn't commenting for me like I don't get
it
I just feel like she is
weighing in and semi like dragging him
for shading this fake accent it's shady
and she deserves that and this is
full-blown confirmation of what we all
already knew like your voice doesn't
sound like that he definitely had a very
low register like in The Carrie Diaries
He was like very sexy he was like this
teenage boy who had like a really low
voice but it's not even close to what it
is now
yeah I also have like a really hot take
like I thought Austin Butler was amazing
in Elvis I thought Elvis was an amazing
movie it I can't even overstate how much
I loved it but I think he was miscast oh
why do you think that I just like
he doesn't like when I I watch videos of
Elvis now like they come up on my
algorithm all the time and like
he just didn't have that Elvis news he
did as much as he could like yeah put on
as much as he could but like
it just he required so much costume and
makeup and extraness when like I think
other people could have done it more
naturally my takeaway from the film was
that I thought he was amazing and I
thought he definitely deserves an Oscar
nomination I don't think the movie was
that great I had a lot of problems with
the film itself
did you feel like it was a movie that
was a real movie Yes Yes it had real
movie like qualities that's good yeah I
think he did an amazing job he did the
best that he could have done but I think
someone who was a little more naturally
Elvis
would have just done a naturally better
job honestly Miles Teller no
I mean like physically there was a lot
of like Prosthetics and everything that
made it like a little campy like a
little costume oh this was was Broad and
big yeah like Elvis Austin's like small
to me that's true actually Elvis was
like a tall King
yeah no that's true
so that's but I loved it I think he
doesn't deserve an Oscar for it but he
deserves nomination I agree it goes to
Brendan Frazier or I'm protesting I
still we should watch the movie I need
to see the whale it's in theaters I
should just like get my fat ass up and
go but like just to treat yourself so so
low it's so nice to go to a movie alone
as a woman in this climate okay fine go
with Ben so he can talk the whole time
literally so like why is this guy like
here and like why is he alone and like
is he wearing Prosthetics who's that
who's that who's that who's that i'm
like [__] I'm literally seeing this
movie for the first time too shut up get
some popcorn get yourself a big soda you
know what
yes that's a nice way to spend the day
you know what I'm like kind of craving
going to the movies now I'm like I have
such a fabulous weekend and like I'm not
gonna cancel any of my plans maybe one
day next week I should just buy the
tickets and like oh why can't you go
this afternoon oh that's actually a
great idea a little matinee Ben is at a
trade show
how can that Spritz
and why don't you go with Shannon
because we have like a Fab Night Out
planned like I want to go out hit the
town go like to the movies no like me
and you should like let's go to Oh
Shannon can make the movies fabulous
again let's go see the stars
we don't know there are swords Justice
for that version of Annie which isn't
the original and isn't the most modern
one but had wonderful moments that the
Catholic dates one yes that was like an
original song to that movie you know the
best one's the original no I think the
one that I grew up with is Kathy Bates
yeah but that one's like
you know a little watered down I liked
it
I like I love it and and they added
scenes and that was really songs who
knew and songs the original is so good
and then the new one is so good too
and then of course live something smells
like it's burning you should go check on
that I'm gonna go check give me a second
oh my God so much drama here at the
toast today earlier Jackie's Wi-Fi went
out for a second like we were on our
interface and she'd bounced now the
house is burning down what do we do
everything I'm holding everything down
here at the at the studio in New York
Theo's here he's asleep so he's not
being much help also like I don't want
to speak it because then I feel like
it'll be true
um I'm like really worried that Theo's
losing his hearing every time I say like
wanna go out or do you wanna eat those
are like his trigger words and he knows
he'll hop up off the bed in the last
couple of weeks I have to say it like
four times and like
and he's like not listening is
everything okay Jax she's back you guys
what happened
all good um the good news is it only
smelled like that in here and then I
went out and the AC repairman is here
and he needed to test the heat so the
heat just came on full blast and it
smelled all right no worries I was
telling everyone about something I'm
going through
do you want to talk to me about it can I
help like I don't really want to like
verbalize it because like once you say
things they become true but like me and
Ben both think like a very
it's very possible maybe we're just
overreacting like Theo might be losing
his hearing
because like well he's just ignoring you
that's also possible like when I say the
things that he loves about like going
off for walks and like he's just like
he's we used to say it like three times
maybe he's just tired
what about when you say
you want to eat that's what I'm saying
like sometimes no actually with the food
he always he's so he's fine he's fine
yeah he's fine I'm just constantly
worried about him you know
I I mean the worrying never stops with
these boys
and I don't even feel sick
well you better rest up before you big
night I love sneezing it's like what
feels better than that
except like when my sneezes smell weird
then I'm like am I dying
yeah that's a fun fact about Claudia if
you get if you're ever close enough to
her to smell a sneeze yeah I think it's
because I have tonsils
I have tonsils oh
not all of my Seasons smell like let's I
don't want to be painted as gross like I
have really good Orcs hygiene I don't
think that's gross
maybe I have like a sinus infection I
don't know it's just something sweet
about you
I have so many problems
okay let's get into our next story which
is really a crazy story trigger warning
suicide there's a lot going on here
I was telling you about it yesterday
Naomi Judd's final note revealed so
Naomi Judd wrote In what appears to be
her chilling suicide note that she did
not want her quote mentally ill daughter
Winona Judd to attend her funeral Radar
Online obtained a photo of the message
written on a yellow Post-It note from
the Williamson County Sheriff's Office
in Tennessee on Tuesday the Post-it note
said quote do not let why come to my
funeral she's mentally ill the word not
was underlined indicating how strongly
Naomi felt about banning Winona from her
services so some images have come out
from the crime scene in her bedroom
where she took her life and seems like
really like
should we be seeing that
I I don't know what the it's like weird
flaws are yeah
um and this note was left with her which
is really shocking a source close to
Winona told the outlet that she's
crushed by her mom's last words a friend
said well I know it's better than anyone
the mental struggles Naomi went through
but it just crushes her to think her
mom's dying thoughts were so vicious
it's also worth remembering that Naomi's
daughters Winona Judd and Ashley Judd
were written out of her will right which
we reported on a few weeks ago or maybe
even months at this point when the when
when the initial news came out right and
so we were like you know we'll just have
to wait and see but it definitely seems
like there's bad blood and now I think
this is like a Beyond confirmation of
just at least where her relationship
with Winona stands I don't know about
Ashley yeah I can't have been amazing if
she didn't leave her anything in her
will right but not as bad on this note
this is like so sad and crazy and it's
like everyone's pointing the finger it's
like now me or in the in the letter
Naomi's like wynonna's mentally ill and
then Wynonna said you know it's so hard
to you know believe any woman believe
what anybody says when they're mentally
ill implying that her mom was so it's
like it's like that Spider-Man meme too
too like who is who's the mentally ill
one right why'd you call her Wynonna
that's what people call her by the way
really yeah who I literally was watching
like Kelsea ballerini's story and she
was like so excited for this year like
I'm doing the Judd tour with Winona
and I'm like fairly certain like if
you're from the south that's how you say
it but like I could be making all of
this up
but no it's it's interesting because I
guess her name is spelled w-y but like
Winona Ryder is w i I think Winona is
such a cute name I think it is too like
if I was a southern girly like I would
like that
yeah but I'm almost positive it's Winona
oh my God okay
um
that's a lot like for me to calibrate
take your time
I will I will work it in
um when reporting on the story but
anyways this like Judd family Saga just
is so crazy crazy
and like I wouldn't say like before all
this happened I was particularly like
you know interested in in their Dynamics
but this is this is crazy
yeah wishing you the best
me as well are you ready for our next
toy which is more sad news is it
unfortunately brought to you
yeah it is introducing the bed by thuma
handcrafted from eco-friendly high
quality upcycled wood the bed has a
modern minimalist design that helps
Elevate any space it's super supportive
for your mattress it's breathable and
it's made to naturally minimize mattress
noise and create space
are you okay did you just have a stroke
no it's super supportive for your
mattress the bed is put together using
the Timeless technique of Japanese
joinery each piece locks into place
meaning no tools or excess Hardware are
required for assembly it has clean lines
subtle curves and lifestyle enhancing
details it is simple sophistication for
the bedroom it's so easy to set up we
set up Jackie's because she has one in
her guest room easy peasy lemon squeezy
it's so stylish it's in margot's room it
looks gorgeous we didn't want to kill
each other and like choke each other
after setting up a bed and just two
little tiny little frail little girls
were able to do it
yeah and the bed once completed is good
enough for the snitch right and that's
all you need to know because when things
are not up to her standards they have to
be swapped the bed is backed with a
lifetime warranty it ships right to your
door in three easy maneuver boxes and
takes about five minutes to set up along
with the bed thuma offers other bedroom
Essentials to elevate bedtime like the
mattress the nightstand the side table
they're perfect compliments to the bed
so create that feeling of just checking
into your favorite boutique hotel suite
but at home with the bed by thuma now go
to thuma.co toast to receive a 25 credit
towards your purchase of the bed plus
free shipping in the continental US go
to thuma.co toast that's t-h-u-m-a dot
Co slash toast for a 25 credit today's
episode is also brought to you by
vegamore we have tried everything to get
that silky strong healthy hair and when
we say everything we mean everything
putting eggs in our hair mayonnaise so
if you're tired of those ineffective
hair treatments and are hungry to try
something that actually works give
vegamore a try like we did because
vagamore has transformed hair their
clean and vegan approach to hair uses
smart Botanicals that promote visibly
thicker fuller and longer looking hair
with help from vegamore you can get
healthy beautiful looking hair but
without the harmful chemicals because
all of their products are cruelty free
and they never contain potentially
harmful chemicals like parabens or
hormones vagamore has something for
everyone looking to improve their hair
Health the gro revitalizing shampoo and
conditioner kit works together to create
visibly thicker hair and improve hair
from the roots just massage the shampoo
into your scalp for 60 seconds and then
follow up with the conditioner on the
lengths and the ends it's as simple as
that having vegamore as your go-to
shampoo is a game changer for your
overall hair health and there is no risk
when trying because they have a 90 day
money back guarantee
but with the 91 percent of customers
saying that they saw visibly thicker
hair with bangamore in just three months
you won't want to run out
give your hair exactly what it's been
craving with vegamore go to vagamore.com
toast and use code toast to save 20 on
your first order that's
v-e-g-a-m-o-u-r.com slash toast code
toast to save 20 at vegamore.com toast
that's a new sponsor be sure to check it
out
check it out you know what that just
reminded me of when in your intro things
we used to put in our hair
olive oil yeah back in the day we were
girls who every summer would come home
from camp with lice
I feel like considering we were four
girls we went to summer camp every
summer we didn't get it that many times
like we could have gotten it more than
we did we had it like a handful of times
but like no we didn't get it until a
little later in life later in life but
then I feel like it was you know five
summers in a row where we got it we
never got it during the school year yeah
and then we would have to sit down
strand by strand someone would pick
through our hair and then for two weeks
we had to sleep with olive oil in our
hair which wasn't the worst the worst
was waking up so early to wash it out
before school before school but it's not
like you could just do shampoo and
conditioner to get olive oil out of your
hair you just use Dawn you have to use
Dawn and you have to like you're a dish
but wait you can't like get in the
shower wet your hair and then use Dawn
you have to do it in the sink and you
couldn't run water on it you had to
lather your hair in the dawn dry but
like with the olive oil scrubs so hard
oh my God it was some of the worst
mornings of my [__] life
yeah and then it's like you don't want
to go to school with a wet head no
you're like trying to blow dry your hair
and no matter school but you're also
like 10. no matter how much you scrubbed
with the dawn you would have like by the
time your hair dried your hair was
[__] oily oh I disagree it wasn't
oily and actually I think the olive oil
is actually really nice for your hair
but the dawn then ruins any progress you
made it but it was a really effective
method of getting rid of lice like once
they sit you down and go through all
with that tiny comb they go through your
entire head it would take hours they
pretty much got everything but to ensure
that you know no they did they got
everything that you can see but then
they are like there could have been eggs
that were laid an hour ago right so you
had to do the olive oil for two weeks
because eggs can lay for up to two weeks
it was it was literally horrible
yeah
so now I was thinking about that no I'm
so glad you brought that up to sleep in
the shower cap about yeah so like after
we would get lathered up we would like
sit and watch TV we couldn't lean back
on the couch all four of us with like
literally stopping wet olive oil hair
wrapped in a shower cap and like a towel
around her yes oh my God and our our
sheets and our pillowcases like were
destroyed every summer but we slept with
towels on our pillows but still it soaks
some of us were rough sleepers yeah it
was horrible horrible
I don't know like now I'm looking back
at it like nostalgically of course but
like that's like when you would couldn't
sleep because your hair was making so
much noise because the shower cap was
like rustling against the towel yeah
horrible
yeah not fun no sir anyways if any of
your kids have lice I'm sorry that like
drugstore [__] like that [__] doesn't
work like you have to yeah no but that's
actually that's really how you get rid
of it like uh two weeks of sleeping with
olive oil in your hair yeah
it's the best way we tried horrible
our next story as stated some more sad
news Leslie Jordan's cause of death has
been confirmed so Leslie Jordan the
Beloved actor died on October 24th at
the age of 67 and his cause of death has
been confirmed as a sudden cardiac
dysfunction the actor died when the
medical event caused him to crash into a
building in Hollywood California
according to according to the LA County
coroner's office and documents obtained
by people from the Department of the
medical examiner coroner they determined
that his death in his car was from
natural causes and listed
artiosclerotic cardiovascular disease as
a secondary Factor there was no evidence
of drugs or alcohol in his system he had
been sober for more than two decades at
the time of his death
so sad like
it's just really sad it's not like
anything like happened you know
yeah I love Alyssa Jordan I feel like
ever since he passed away and I feel
like this happens a lot with like famous
people who pass away like their content
gets served to you more I don't know if
like more people are searching for them
but like they're well he also was a
Content King yeah and he really popped
off in the last couple of years even
though he's been acting for you know so
long
um but I feel like I'm like constantly
being reminded of him and like how
genuinely funny he was and it's just sad
yeah it's really sad
I'm glad that they confirmed what had
happened because it was a bit of a
mystery right
um and that there wasn't anything
nefarious I didn't know he was sober for
so long that's awesome me neither that
is awesome I love that
yeah so our fifth and final story
um little Kelly news oh thank God
Kelly Clarkson has been granted
restraining orders against two alleged
stalkers is it us literally that was the
joke I was gonna make [__] sorry the
Grammy winner was granted permanent
restraining orders against two alleged
stalkers on Thursday TMZ reported per
the outlet the individuals Claudia
are prohibited just kidding their names
are not us are prohibited for making
contact of any kind with Clarkson or her
children
um for the next five years additionally
they must reportedly stay at least 100
yards away from the family the
perpetrators have allegedly showed up at
her La home on multiple occasions and
caused disturbances oh my God like Kelly
is constantly going through stuff like
can't she just be America's sweetheart
build her business like in peace like if
it's out the divorce it's a stalker like
stop like leave her alone everyone is
always coming for Kelly's deck and she
could have been doing and it's like this
country and this country does nothing
for her we couldn't be more obsessed
with Kelly but you don't see us stalking
her you know like you could be a fan if
we can control ourselves so can you so
can you
I thought the story was going to be that
Kelly did a nine to five like cover she
made a music video and everything oh
it's so cute she's literally so she did
a nine to five cover like on it's been
on Spotify for a while oh so then I
guess she officially made a music video
because I saw it this morning when I was
like scrolling before I had to get out
of bed
um she made the cutest little music
video you know she was stumbling out of
bed tumbling to the kitchen pouring
herself a cup of ambition yawning
stretching just basically trying to come
to life
um it was adorable
that's so cute yeah she has a nine to
five cover I'm glad there's a music a
video for it but the thing about Kelly
is that she works so much more than nine
to five Kelly does the five to nine and
then the nine to five yeah like
she does her nine to five Kelly Clarkson
show and then after that she's a mother
she's a singer she's a performer like
she's she's an author an author do you
think that we will literally he's a
Furniture designer right it's way fair
for Kelly Clarkson or Kelly Clarkson for
Wayfair do you think Kelly will ever go
on tour again I feel like I've asked you
that because like with her new life
yes when she puts out her next album I
think she will go on tour because I
think she likes touring I know but how
does it the Kelly Clarkson show
she'll go in the off season I think
she'll tour she knows the fans want to
see her what was her last tour
I think the love so soft
meaning of life meaning of life and she
had like a bar on stage
I didn't go to that tour no me neither
I'm like I didn't know it was going to
be the last one definitely why don't ask
me because we didn't know it was going
to be the last one for a decade
yeah
lots of people announcing tours Madonna
just announced one oh yeah I saw that
video she had a bunch of friends over
yeah that was like really desperate I
was shocked by that um like kind of
desperate attempt from I like I was
watching because and weirdly I got I saw
it because I followed Diplo and he was
arrested and he said like didn't know
what this dinner was when I was invited
and so I found out from Diplo that Matan
is going on like a world tour of her
Greatest Hits and
and then but I didn't see it anywhere
else okay I want to say something and I
this is an extremely extremely hot take
and I know people are gonna maybe
disagree with me and that's fine I'm not
saying my opinion is the right opinion
it's just my opinion but like my POV of
Madonna and I was not alive for like the
real Heyday like I know she was like the
Taylor Swift I know I know 80s 90s maybe
even in the early 2000s but everything
I've seen of Madonna in the last 10
years is is genuinely pathetic every
time I see her like do something it
actually makes me sad
um everything she does is desperate I
can't I can't even imagine that they're
and I know I know that nobody agrees
with me and I just want to say like I'm
not saying I'm right but like I can't
even imagine there being someone who
wants to buy a ticket to her concert but
I know she's going to do Arenas all
around the world I know I'm just like
shocked like
I think you know
she like wakes up every day trying to
recapture the magic of the 80s like
that's how I perceive it and I know
that's like not maybe not accurate but
that's how I see it
yeah I don't think she's doing herself a
lot of favors in her social media
content like everything interviews
anything I ever see with Madonna Like
It's never premium yeah and it's never
like
I feel like keeping her Legacy
in a strong place like and I I disagree
that people won't want to go see her
like people want to go and I'm breathing
I'm saying I know that there are I
cannot even imagine no but I can imagine
someone who's like 80s 90s and those are
their hits and like no they don't want
to who else are they gonna see they want
to see their people in concert it would
be like in 20 years you going to see
Taylor Swift while she performs songs
from today but like no no
I think Madonna's tours and this one too
are going to be like on the level of
Taylor Swift she's gonna do Stadium
she's gonna go Global and the way I see
I see her like a share
yeah Cher does like tours but it's only
um you know Greatest Hits she's not
really seeing new music and it's never
it's not even close to the scale of what
Madonna's have been and I think this one
will be Madonna's is very much on the
same level as like Elton John and Elton
John I totally understand like to me
he's still so relevant in culture
without being like a desperate kind of
like has been Vibe
um
the Madonna Madonna like it just doesn't
make sense to me
yeah you know what Madonna needs
she needs a movie like Rocket Man and
Bohemian Rhapsody she needs one I agree
with that I think that would help people
like us understand the obsession it was
like the same people who made Rocket Man
and Bohemian Rhapsody right they had
like such the same Vibe they didn't have
the same Vibe but like the marketing
no they just came out at the same time
Rocket Man was like like Confessions of
a teenager it was so good like like
the uh more like musical comedy yeah and
Bohemian Rhapsody was very serious and
the guy who made it was like a big
pedophile question marked
uh the memory was a whole Scandal and no
one wanted to nominate the movie for
anything is it Brian Singer um
yeah yeah oh
what's his I don't know if he's a
pedophile I think he's you know Classic
Hollywood you know
no such thing as no me too Vibe no such
thing as him he was reportedly up to his
old tricks on the Bohemian Rhapsody set
what are his old tricks yeah he's a
controversial one
but it's not kids see that's why
Hollywood is such like so [__]
hypocrisy like me too they made this
whole thing like hashtag time's up
they're all wearing pins and then the
next year they got Brian Singer making
movies for everyone like please don't
tell me you actually care you don't so
just stop pretending in 1997 a 14 year
old extra accused singer of asking him
and other miners to film a shower scene
nude for the film apt pupil two other
adolescent boys 16 and 17 years old
later supported the 14 year old's claim
so like I said like nobody in Hollywood
actually cares Brian singer's former
employee partner details years of
alleged abuse
so he abused his assistant he's accused
of molesting and raping underage boys oh
my God
okay that's disgusting and honestly the
film shouldn't be nominated
yeah I don't know what if it wound up
winning anything but then like the
argument is like well oh the argument
was like well like what about the
lighting you know people worked really
hard on this movie but like Ramy Malik
was amazing
wait you know no you're talking you said
he did
Rocket Man Brian Singer no he did
Bohemian rhaps oh uh Rami Malek was
amazing
but see that's what people it's honestly
on people in Hollywood who have power
like Rami Malek and Lucy to say I'm not
working with this director like nobody
actually cares
they just did it like performatively to
wear the pin on the Oscars hashtag
time's up you know if this is finally
coming thank God and nobody actually did
anything so you know what I don't care
about these people and I don't know why
we all look to them as like some sort of
Role Models when they're so morally
corrupt like Faye Resnick couldn't even
yeah
so those are that's our stories we need
someone who's a wonderful pillar of
society to make a Madonna biopic yes and
I think it should be
Kenny Ortega it's by the way I don't
know why Kenny Ortega never
um like evolved past Disney into doing
like large-scale theatrical musical
Productions like for Hollywood like
Kenny Ortega so talented he could win
Oscars he's got what it takes you know I
fell down a rabbit hole and I got
pranked because
um
like it was going around that Jenna
Ortega was Kenny Ortega's like niece or
something and it actually made a lot of
sense you know
yeah she's not there's no relation
that's really funny it was a good one
though I got Christ
what's it you got one when you get
chrised
what's that
um like it's this thing where like you
prank someone on the internet and then
like you say something crazy and then
right after you say it you put that
little video of Kris Jenner dancing get
you get you yeah yeah it's that like I
got you and it's called getting Chris
looks like getting pranked that's so
funny I've not heard of any of this no
it's like Jackie and I are devastated to
announce that this will be our final
episode of the toast ever
get you get you yeah yeah you've been
chrised
I don't love a prank
um a harmless prank I'm okay with
yeah but do they ever stop no people
don't know the line no they don't people
take it too far
yeah so those are the Fast Five this was
our final episode of the week it was
fabulous hanging out with you guys all
week Jack's always a pleasure you two as
well McLaren hope everyone has a great
weekend whether that's being productive
being lazy getting drunk rearing
children whatever it is it's all equally
as valuable
um so thank you so much for listening to
the toast the millennial Morning Show
where we deliver the fastest stories
they need to know every Monday through
Friday on YouTube if you're watching
this on YouTube please don't forget to
subscribe give this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast wait
before I leave I just want Theo wants to
say bye
Oh My Sweet Angel
can he hear me no it's been a while
since Theo's been on the show so
everyone he just wanted to say Ro thank
you all so much I love you all and I
love the toast because it really helps
make my mom a star that's what he said
thank you so much for listening today
to everybody Friday on YouTube for
watching us on YouTube please feel free
to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as
podcast anywhere podcast can be found so
at Spotify iTunes Stitch Republic video
I have read a castbox all the places
five star review about a beautiful
starting and working later hope you guys
have an incredib weekend and we'll see
you on Monday
love ya bye